hi welcome to Google my name is David
white and I'm going to talk to you today
about running your Windows workloads on
Google cloud I'm a solution manager here
at Google in the infrastructure
modernization group and before joining
Google I've spent most of my career as a
CEO o CIO VP of IT essentially I spent
more of my time as the customer that on
this side of the table so I want to talk
to you a little bit today about why
customers are running their Microsoft
workloads on GCP talk a little bit about
Microsoft licensing options in GCP and
then we'll talk about phase
transformation of your Microsoft
workloads and your Microsoft
applications so the first question that
we often hear is why on earth would
anybody bring Microsoft workloads to
Google cloud and I think this but more
than anything else answers at best or
worst or so soon our senior vice
president of engineering and technical
infrastructure we're committed to making
GCP a first-class platform for running
Microsoft workloads and if you look back
over the last five years since he made
that statement Google has continued to
invest yet optimizing and modernizing
and bringing in the technologies and
tools that allow you to bring your
enterprise Microsoft workloads into
Google cloud today thousands of our
customers are running Windows workloads
in Google cloud amounting to billions of
core hours every year of Windows
workloads some of our recent customers
including traffic's involution and most
recently tell us international talk
about how they have brought their
Windows workloads into Google and what a
great decision it's been so why do
people want to bring Microsoft workloads
into Google first and foremost Google
has phenomenal infrastructure between
our underlying compute capabilities the
speed of our storage the robustness of
our network and the security that we
bake into everything Google always wants
to make sure that we provide the best
for our customers that we can google
also preferences giving customers choice
we want to be able to provide an array
of offerings so that customers can
choose which different pieces are going
to fit their solutions best and Google
first and for
most is committed to modernization and
to an open platform we are devoted to
the open source community and we are the
innovators behind things like kubernetes
tensorflow gke and other tools that are
commonly used today throughout a variety
of clouds so let's talk a little bit
about our three staged approach first is
to migrate so we help you with the lift
and shift moving from your on-premises
data center into Google Cloud migrating
your VMs into our Google compute engine
and potentially even upgrading those
versions of the operating system where
possible I'll talk a little bit more
about that in a moment this is using our
migrate for compute engine tool by doing
this we work with you to get the right
balance of your bring your own licensing
capabilities versus that pay-as-you-go
licensing we help you take advantage of
Google technology such as CPU over
commit and custom VM shapes and we allow
you to leverage suspending and resuming
your VMs so that you can save on costs
when things aren't actually needed next
we'll talk a little bit about our
modernization opportunities these are
the ways in which we can help you bring
your Windows applications into
containers and still be in Windows or
taking advantage of our fully managed
service offerings like cloud sequel or
managed Active Directory and all of this
results in a greater efficiency tighter
bin packing and better cost optimization
lastly we can talk about how we can help
you transform your applications moving
to more open standards like Postgres or
my sequel or moving your dotnet on
windows into dotnet core or lastly
taking your dotnet applications in
container izing them for ease of
management and ease of scale where do I
go
as I said Google wants to provide you a
variety of choices so that you can
choose per workload what the best
destination is for your Windows
applications first choice is the Google
compute engine this is our standard
Google VM environment where we can help
you bring your on-prem VMs using our
migrate for compute engine
if there are applications that it makes
more sense to stay in vmware we can help
you stay in vm we are with our vmware as
a service offering allows you to
leverage native vmware tools like hcx to
do your migrations and helps you move
those workloads from vmware on-premises
into vmware in google cloud where you
can still take advantage of all of the
Google cloud features and services
lastly for those items that are
appropriate to containerize we can help
you with our migrated 4 anthos tool to
take your dotnet applications that are
running in VMs today and actually put
them into windows containers running in
kubernetes similarly for Microsoft
sequel you have the opportunity to
continue running your own Microsoft
sequel on Windows in our Google compute
engine in a virtual machine or we can
help you migrate to sequel for Linux
thus eliminating the need to pay for the
underlying operating system of Windows
because Linux is free or if you want to
get out of the business of managing your
own sequel server we can help you move
to cloud sequel where we need words a
fully managed service offering and you
just need to tap in so a little bit of
an overview on licensing with a quick
disclaimer this is guidance at best
please make sure that you check the
details of your individual Microsoft
licensing so essentially there are two
models for how you can take care of your
microsoft licenses within Google Cloud
the first is very easy and
straightforward is just pay-as-you-go if
you'd like to deploy a Microsoft Windows
server in Google cloud when you're
creating that VM you select the windows
server image and that image will not
only have the Windows server operating
system it will also have the necessary
licensure and that gets billed on a per
second basis you spin it up the billing
starts you spin it down the billing
stops
similarly for sequel server if you'd
like to select one of our Windows images
that has sequel server already installed
we can charge you per minute for the
time that that sequel server is up and
then when that sequel server is down the
billing stops this is particularly
useful for tests or dev or staging
environments that don't need to run 24/7
that you want to be able to bring up and
bring down similarly for other Microsoft
applications like SharePoint or Exchange
we leverage our third-party partners
that are able to provide images and
pay-as-you-go licensing in cost for our
BYO licenses we offer our sole tenant
nodes which we'll discuss in a moment
your eligibility to bring your own
license will still depend on your Marcus
off licensure but where you are entitled
to bring your licenses our sole tenant
nodes allow you the place to do that
with dedicated Hardware sequel server by
the terms of your Software Assurance you
have the ability to bring your sequel
server licenses wherever you'd like as
well as SharePoint and Exchange in other
Microsoft applications this is the use
case for 24 by 7 applications where you
need to keep them running all the time
so some people have discussed October
2019 when it comes to Microsoft licenses
there was a change based on October 2019
for licenses purchased after that vs.
licenses purchased before that for
Windows Server licenses purchased before
2000 before October of 2019 as long as
these licenses were purchased prior to
that or associated with larger
agreements that were created prior to
that you should be able to bring those
Windows licenses to GCP within the the
guardrails within the boundaries of your
Microsoft license for sequel server as
long as you have Software Assurance
you're able to continue to bring those
licenses over to Google in order to make
sure that we have all of our eyes dotted
and t's crossed we've engaged the
services of a third party company called
software one software one is a premier
partner of both Google and Microsoft and
has provided
prescriptive guidance on the details of
Microsoft licensure and as you can see
in both cases Windows Server and sequel
server there is likely a path to be able
to bring those licenses over one of the
requirements for being in compliance
with Microsoft licensing is the ability
to generate a report of the operating
system and the servers that they're
running on Google takes that complexity
away by providing these reports for you
on demand now as I mentioned sole tenant
nodes sole tenant nodes mean that you
have sole control over the underlying
hardware for the virtual machines that
you're deploying you can mix and match
Linux and Windows VMs on those sole
tenant nodes but in addition you can
flip a switch that allow you to trigger
a CPU over commit essentially what that
means is you make it appear as though
there's twice as many CPUs available on
that host and for those applications
that are not overly resource intensive
it allows you to pack twice as many VMs
on to that same hardware so you can get
much more cost-effective use of that
underlying hardware that you're now
using custom VMS are an outstanding tool
for sequel server so a sequel server is
licensed by CPU but is very very ram
hungry for many cloud providers what
that means is in order to get the
additional memory that sequel wants you
have to increase your V CPU count
meaning you're not only being charged
for the CPU cores but you're also having
to pay licensure for sequel and windows
for those additional CPUs that you
really don't need with custom VMs in GCP
we allow you to scale that RAM and CPU
core separately so that you can create
that custom shape that's going to give
you the optimal amount of RAM for your
sequel server or other applications
while still not having to overpay for
CPUs that you don't actually need
Windows Server 2008 is another topic
that we frequently hear from our
customers
Windows Server 2008 r2 has gone
end-of-life which means that Microsoft
will no longer provide security updates
or patches for it without having to
purchase potentially expensive extended
security updates migrate for compute
engine allows you to take those 2008 r2
servers from your data center and in the
process of migration actually upgrade
them in flight so that when they land in
GCE they land as 2012 servers which is a
fully supported operating system that is
provided at no cost to our customers by
using the different tools and technology
that Google provides optimizing your per
second billing being able to shape the
custom VMs taking advantage of
preemptable VMs so for those workloads
that just need episodic access to
compute you can spin them up and spin
them down at a greatly reduced price we
also have an ongoing recommendation
system where you can see at a VM by VM
level what the recommendations are for
scaling up or scaling down based on your
actual utilization of those VMs
allowing you to right-size your spend
and right-size your utilization of
resources let's talk a little bit now
about modernizing so some of the ways
that we help you modernize around sequel
by moving to sequel on Linux for example
you remove the underlying need to
license the Windows operating system by
moving to manage sequel you don't have
to pay the sequel license costs at all
because all of that is managed within
our cloud sequel offering and by moving
that responsibility of management we may
even be able to help you move from
enterprise to standard to web and as you
can see moving from server Enterprise to
sitt sequel server standard can be a
tremendous cost savings being able to
move all the way to sequel server web
can be at phenomenal cost savings window
server containers in gke this is our
ability to support windows containers
that can either be spun up from scratch
or can come over as a result of our
microwave for an 'those tool that can
pick up your VMs from your data center
and deliver them as containers in
kubernetes one of the best advantages of
container izing these applications is
license cost with your Microsoft
licenses once the underlying VM host has
been licensed for the operating system
you can deploy as many containers on top
of that operating system as the hardware
will support so again this provides much
better bin packing much greater
efficiency much more cost effective use
of the resources you're already paying
for our managed service offering for
Active Directory allows you to get out
from under the burden of having to
manage your Active Directory
infrastructure and still be able to use
it as the security and profiling tool
that you want to be able to use it for
typically what we see when we sit down
and we work with customers on optimizing
their costs once they've moved their
Microsoft workloads into GCP is we can
see as much as a 50% cost savings by
blending your BYO licenses in your
pay-as-you-go licenses by being able to
take advantage of the CPU over commit
and using some of the other tools and
technology that Google provides which
allows you to then take that savings and
reinvest it in your transformation this
is where you really want to end up when
all is said and done this is moving into
cloud native this is moving into open
source this is what gives you the
scalability and the flexibility that
really underpin your digital
transformation so being able to move
from sequel server to Postgres or my
sequel or helping you migrate your
dotnet for Windows applications onto
dotnet core that runs on Linux or even
just container izing your dotnet
applications so you can start making
incremental steps towards
containerization using our google
kubernetes engine or possibly even going
into anthos ultimately we want to be
able to partner with you to look at your
Microsoft workloads and help you
identify which applications should be
retired which ones can be migrated into
GCP such as third-party is V
applications which internally created
applications are easy rewrites such as
moving from dotnet to dotnet core or
which ones are going to be more
complicated or that may yield better
results by moving into things like
serverless through App Engine and cloud
run and then ultimately what are the
applications that you're just going to
have to maintain until their
functionality is completely replaced
with other applications so in summary we
want to help you start at the left with
your Microsoft workloads and your
Microsoft servers running in your
on-premises location lift and shift and
migrate them into Google cloud using our
tools and technologies working with you
to optimize and get the right balance of
spend for your compute and for your
licensure and then ultimately help you
through your digital transformation into
cloud native and open source thank you
and we look forward to working with you
in the future